you know they've hired guido now and
they've hired a lot of python developers
he retired then he came out of
retirement and he's working out i was
just talking to him and he didn't
mention this person well i should i
should have invested further
because i know he loved dropbox but i
wasn't sure what he was doing who he was
up to well he was kind of saying he'd
retire but uh and it's it's literally
been
five years since i last sat out and
really talked to guido right
guido is a technology
expert right he's a so i came i was
excited because i finally figured out
the type system for for numbai i wanted
to kind of talk about that with him and
i kind of overwhelmed him could you stay
in that just for a brief moment because
you're a fascinating person in the
history of program and he is a
fascinating person what have you learned
from guido about
programming about life yeah yeah a lot
actually i've been a fan of guidos you
know we have a chance to talk some i
wouldn't say you know we talk all the
time not only at all he may um but we
talked enough to i respect his like when
i first started numpy one of the first
things i did was i had a i asked guido
for a meeting
with him and paul dubois in san mateo
and i went and met him for lunch and
basically to say maybe we can actually
part of the strategy for numpy was to
get it into python 3 and maybe be part
of python so we talked about that that's
cool about that approach right i would
loved to be a fly in the world that was
that was good and over over the years
for guido i learned
so he was open like
he was willing to listen to people's
ideas
right and you know over the years now
generally you know i'm not saying
universally that's been true but but
generally that's been true so he's
willing to listen he's willing to defer
like on the scientific side he would
just kind of defer he didn't really
always understand what we were doing
like
and he'd defer one place where he didn't
enough
was we missed a matrix multiply operator
like that finally got added to python
but about 10 years later than it should
have but the reason was because nobody
it took it takes a lot of effort and i
learned this while i was writing numpy i
also wrote tools to i became a python
dev and i added some pieces of python um
like the memory view object i wanted the
structure of numpy into python so we
didn't get numpy into python but we got
the basic structure of it into python
like so you could build on it nobody did
for a while but eventually database
authors started to and it was it's a lot
better they did and also antoine petro
and stefan craw actually fixed the
memory view object because i wrote the
underlying infrastructure in c but the
python exposure was terrible
until they came in and fixed it partly
because i was writing numpy and numpy
was the python exposure i didn't really
care about if you didn't have numpy
installed anyway guido
opened up ideas technology you know
brilliant like really
i really got a lot of respect from when
i saw what he did with the clap with the
this type class merger thing that was
actually tricky right and then
and then willing to share willing to
share his ideas so the other thing early
on in 1998 i said i start wrote my first
extension module the reason i could is
because he wrote this blog post on how
to do reference counting
right and without it i would have been
lost right but he was he was willing to
at least try to write this post and so
he's been motive he's been motivated
early on with python there's a computer
science for everybody we kind of have
this early on desire to oh maybe we
should be pushing programming to more
people so he had this
populist notion i guess or populist
sense
um to learn that
there's a certain skill and i've seen it
in other people too
of engaging with contributors
sufficiently to because when somebody
engages with you and wants to contribute
to you if you ignore them they go away
so building that early contributor base
requires real engagement
with other people and he would do that
can you also comment on this tragic
uh stepping down from his position as
the benevolent dictator for life
over the wars
uh uh you know the walrus operator the
walrus operator was the last battle i
don't know if that's the cause of it but
uh this there's this for people who
don't know you can look up there's the
walrus operator which is uh looks like a
colon and equal sign yeah equal sign and
um
it actually does
may be the thing that you
that an equal sign should be doing yeah
maybe right exactly uh yeah but it's
just historically equal sign means
something else it just means assignment
so he stepped down over this what do you
think about the pressure of leadership
some of that you mentioned the letter i
wrote in numpy at the time that was a
hard time actually i mean you know
there's been really hard times it was
hard you know
you get criticized right and you get
pushed and you get um not everybody
loves what you do like anytime you do
anything that has impact at all
you're not universally loved right you
get some real critics and that's an
important energy because
it's impossible if you do everything
right you need people to be pushing but
sometimes people can get mean yeah
people can
i i i prefer to give people to benefit
the doubt i don't immediately assume
they have bad intentions
and maybe for other you know maybe other
maybe that doesn't happen for everybody
they for whatever reason their past or
experience with people they sometimes
have bad and they they so they
immediately attribute to you bad
intentions they're like where this come
from i mean i definitely open the
criticism but i think you're
misinterpreting the whole point
uh because i i would get that you know
certainly when i started anaconda you
know i've been
sometimes i say to people uh i know i'm
i care enough about entrepreneurship to
make some open source people
uncomfortable
and i care enough about open source to
make investors uncomfortable
so i sort of you know create you create
kind of doubters on both sides so when
you have and this is just a
a plea to the listener and the public
i've noticed this too
that
there's a tendency and social media
makes this worse
when you don't have perfect information
about the situation you tend to fill the
gaps with the
the worst possible or at least a bad
uh story that fills those gaps and
i think it's good to live life
uh maybe not fully naively but filling
in the gaps with the with the with the
good with the
best with the positive with the with the
hopeful explanation of why you see this
so if you see somebody like you trying
to make money on a book about numpy
there's a million stories around that
that are positive and those are good to
think about uh to uh project positive
intent on the people because
for many reasons usually because people
are good and they do have good intent
and also when you project that positive
intent people step up to that
too yes so like it's it has a great
point it has this kind of viral nature
to it and of course what twitter early
on figured out on facebook is that they
can make a lot of money and engagement
from the negative yes so like there's
this we're finding this mechanism i
agree which is challenging easier it's
just easier to be to be negative and
then for some reason something in our
minds really enjoys sharing that and
getting getting all excited about the
negativity we do yeah but but the
protective mechanism perhaps that we're
we're going to eat if we don't exactly
for us to be effective as a group of
people in the software engineering
project you have to project positive
intent i think i totally agree totally
agree and i think that's very and so
that that happens in this in the space
but python has done a reasonable job in
the past but here is a situation where i
think it's it's starting to get this
pressure where it didn't i was i really
didn't i didn't know enough about what
happened i've you know talked to several
people about it and i know
i think most of the steering committee
members today
uh one one person nominated me for that
role but it's the wrong role for me
right now right
i have a lot of respect for the python
developer space and the python
developers i also understand the gap
between computer science python
developers and array programming
developers or science developers and in
fact python succeeds in the array space
the more it has people in that boundary
and there's often very few like i was
playing a role in that boundary and you
know working like everything to try to
keep up with the
with the what even what guido was saying
like
i'm a c programmer but not a computer
scientist like i was a engineer and
physicist and mathematician and i don't
i didn't always understand what they
were talking about and why they would
have opinions the way they did so you
have to listen and try to understand
then you also have to explain your point
of view in a way they can understand and
that takes a lot of work and that that
communication is always the challenge
and it's just what we're describing here
about the negativity is just another
form of that like how do we come
together and it does appear we're wired
anyway to at least have a there's a part
of us that little enemy you know friend
enemy and
and we see yeah it's like why are we
wiring on the enemy front yeah so so why
are we pushing that why are we promoting
that so deeply let's assume friend until
proven otherwise yes yes
so because you have such a fascinating
mind and all this let me just ask you
these questions so one interesting side
on the python
history is the move from python 2 to
python 3. you mentioned move from python
1 to python 2 but
the move from python 2 to python 3 is a
little bit interesting because it took a
very long time
it uh it broke
in a quite a small way backward
compatibility but even that small way
seemed to have been very painful for
people is there lessons
tons of lessons from uh from how long it
took and how painful it seemed to be
yeah tons of lessons well i mentioned
here earlier that
numpy was written in 2005.
it was in 2005 that i actually went to
guido to talk about getting numpy into
python 3. like my strategy was to oh
we're moving to python three let's have
that be and it seems funny in retrospect
because like wait python three that was
in 20 20 20 right when we finally
ended up supporting python two or at
least 2017. the reason it took a long
time a lot of time i think it was
because but one of the things is there
wasn't much to like about python 3. 3.0
3.1 it really wasn't until 3.3 like i
consider python 3.3 to be python 3.0
but it wasn't until python 3.3 that i
thought there's enough stuff in it to
make it worth anybody using it
right and then 3 4 started to be oh yeah
i want that and then 3 5 as the matrix
multiply operator and now it's like okay
we got to use that plus the libraries
just start leveraging the some of the
features of python exactly yeah so it
really the challenge was it was
but it also illustrated a truism that
you know it's when you have an earth
show and you have a pop we have a group
of people using something it's really
hard to move them away from it you can't
just change the world on them and python
3 you know made some i think it fixed
some things guido had always hated i
don't think he didn't like the fact
print was a statement he wanted to make
it a function but in some sense there's
a bit of gratuitous change to the
language and
you could argue and there's people have
there was
one of the challenges was there wasn't
enough features and too many just
changes
without features and
so that empathy for the end user as to
why they would switch wasn't wasn't
there i think also it illustrated just
the funding realities like python wasn't
funded like it was also a project with a
bunch of volunteer labor
right it had more people so more
volunteer labor but it was still
it was fun under the sense that at least
guido had a job and i i've learned some
of the behind the scenes on that now
since since talking to people who lived
through it and
uh maybe not on air we can talk about
some of that
but it's interesting to see but guido
had a job but he but his full-time job
wasn't just work on python yeah like he
had other things to do
just wild it is wild isn't it as well
how few people are funded yes how much
impact they have yes
maybe that's a feature not a bug i don't
know maybe yes exactly at least early on
like it's sort of i know yeah it's like
olympic athletes are often severely
underfunded but maybe that's what brings
out the greatness perhaps yes correct no
exactly
maybe this is the essential part of it
because i do think about that in terms
of i currently have an incubator for
open source startups like what i'm
trying to do right now is create the
environment i wish that existed when i
was leaving academia with numpy and
trying to figure out what to do i'm
trying to create those opportunities and
environments so
uh and that's that's what drives me
still is how do i make the world easier
for the open source entrepreneur
you